is it true you tried to purchase the
brady bunch house but hd
tv sniped it out from under you that is
true
yes um i had this you know one of my tv
shows i wanted to do was this show where
you take iconic
homes from film and television and you
redo them you know and like put them
back on the market whatever
um so i always knew if the brady bunch
ever came for sale
i was going to do this show so uh
you know it you know went up for sale
i'm like i got this i'm doing it so
you know we started this amazing bidding
war with miley cyrus and all these other
people like it was a kind of a fun
event right um and
i called hgtv and i was like hey you
know if i get this house i want to do a
show
on hgtv where we you know redo these
houses
well that was a mistake because guess
what
after two weeks of bidding and
the real estate agent calls he's like
congratulations you got the house like
you have the winning bid
and we're like this is amazing we
celebrate i tweeted i'm like i'm gonna
do the brady house blah blah blah
um the next day they call they're like
oh sorry
hgtv has called and said that they're
just gonna give us whatever money we
want like they'll outbid anyone
so i was like well why did we have a
bidding war for two weeks and spending a
lot of money on lawyers doing bidding
for two weeks when you're just going to
give it to a network
at the end they were using us to put up
the price leverage because they knew it
you should have
i hope that's terrible what can you do
i mean it's not technically illegal so
so you didn't watch when they redid the
house did you even watch that or you're
like them
i did actually um because hdtv wanted me
to play nice because when the fans found
out that they stole it
they got a lot of heat and people were
like boycotting the show already like
room never watched the show
so they called me they're like we would
love you to be involved you know like
because
you're like you can at least produce the
show with us like fine i'll help produce
it
that never happened they were just
basically lying to me to get me out of
the way and not talk
about them um and then they did
let me do um i got to tour the house
with michael
and it was incredible oh my gosh it was
a dream
it was it was incredible so we got to
tour the whole house and we did the
behind the scenes type of stuff for
their
uh their website and all that but it was
they did a really spectacular job can
you still can you actually i would die i
i honestly i would do anything i would
donate whatever to charity
if you could somehow get me a private
tour of that house oh that can happen
yeah i'm look i'm still trying to buy
the house because http still doesn't
know what they want to do with the house
and i'm like why would i work on a house
like sell it to me like
let's like why why would you want to
hold on to this house like give it to
someone that
really wants this house uh well you know
what why don't we come up with a sitcom
and it could just have all the brady
bunch
furniture and the house and the inside
and we just do our own show
i'm like why why are all this furniture
60 years old i don't know
we never talk about it